avant le coc vide tout le monde était
très sûr de soi et on en est il même à
se dire que vous pouvez être éternel on
pouvait choisir d'être de de passer par
dessus tout les contraintes de la nature
on était devenus des demi-dieux
peut-être même trois quarts de dieu j'ai
peur qu'à l'issue de tout ça alors on
est plus confiant sans rien ni en
soignant les néant les autres et qu'on
soit toujours en recul par rapport à
l'aise
j'ai le sentiment qu'on est passé d'une
période d'angoissé ou la situation était
menaçante et on espérer une sortie mais
on se demandait encore comment ça
pouvait arriver
et quels dégâts ça fait surseoir à une
période d'un puissant sa reprise
il n'y a plus la place pour le blabla un
produit il ya plus d'improvisation de
spontanéité il n'y a plus que des
objectifs planifiés véhiculée par
véhicule et par le net et le numérique
et ça je crois que c'est quelque chose
dont les gens souffrent
et oui à côté positif
ça permet de se rendre compte que seul
avec soi même on est pas si bien que ça
et que ce qui donne le goût de la vie le
sens de la vie c'est le partage
et ça je crois que beaucoup de gens
m'avaient oublié parce qu'ils pensaient
que ce qui était important c'est de se
faire plaisir à soi
[Musique]